on the trail of a detective story
that's how the world health organization
has described its mission to uncover the
origins of the pandemic in wuhan
and touring an animal healthcare
facility these scientists were upbeat
about their work
[Music]
they visited hospitals and the seafood
market where the first covert 19 cases
were detected
one year since the beginning of the
outbreak the un agency says seeing the
sites first
hand is important they are having very
productive discussions with
chinese counterparts visiting different
hospitals around wuhan
they've had a very good visit to the
market seeing firsthand
the stalls and walking through and we
had some good feedback from them of the
importance of being able to physically
walk through
but the mission is politically sensitive
on monday
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
raised questions over beijing's
willingness to provide the who with
adequate access
and accurate information the mission has
included visits to an exhibition
depicting wuhan medical workers as
heroes
and to a cold chain storage facility
state media here have suggested the
virus was imported to china
through frozen food beijing has rejected
criticism
saying the who should conduct a similar
investigation in the u.s
the u.s center for disease control says
coronavirus
antibodies were identified there in
december 2019.
we hope like china the u.s will also
take positive
cooperative attitudes in pursuing the
origin of the virus
and invite who experts to america
the who says all hypotheses are on the
table
but the trip has been tightly controlled
the team of members with expertise in
virology
food safety and veterinary science plan
to speak to some of the first
coronavirus patients
and visit wuhan's institute of virology
that's where dangerous pathogens
including coronaviruses
were being studied the whole mission to
ruhan took
months of negotiation to agree with the
chinese government
team members who have spoken to al
jazeera say their field work could also
take months
even years they've asked the
international community to be patient
and to avoid any cynicism about their
investigation
katrina u al jazeera beijing